est devenu préposé au début de la
pandémie j'ai répondu à l'appel puis
sans trop de savoir ça a bousculé ça
bousculé positivement ma vie toi parce
que au chocolat il tombe un amour avec
le métier aider les aînés et pour lui un
grand bonheur mais sans privilégié de
pouvoir donner au suivant 8000 recrues
du programme de 2020 sont comme Clément
restés dans le métier mais il faut
maintenant susciter d'autres vocations
c'est à dire de recruter du nouveau
personnel Québec lance un deuxième grand
programme de formation d'ici janvier on
veut recruter 5000 futurs préposés
chaque candidat aux candidate aura droit
à une bourse de 12000 dollars
inscrivez-vous il y a il y aura une
cinquantaine de centres de services à
travers le Québec qui vont offrir la
formation de 3
75 heures donc 375 heures sur 12
semaines une autre Couarde sera lancée
dès le début 2024 parce qu'il manque
déjà 11000 préposés dans le réseau de la
santé d'ici 2027
cet écart là donc le besoin additionnel
pourrait être de l'ordre 15 à 20 000
personnes alors il faut vraiment faire
un effort
on souhaite recruter des jeunes mais
aussi des retraités quel beau mix j'ose
dire ça comme ça d'avoir des jeunes et
d'avoir des retraités avec l'expérience
pour venir nous aider
preuve que c'est possible Clément est
devenu préposé à l'aube de la
soixantaine
on a une femme pour Clément c'est un
métier fantastique mais qui reste très
exigeant on a besoin personnel on a
besoin d'aide mais de gens qui
sont là pour les bonnes raisons canberge
pomme orange ça veut dire être patient
et capable de beaucoup d'écoute dans cet
univers où tout se passe plus lentement
ici David gentil les radios Canada
Montréal